Speaker 1: Speaking of brainwashing, I am
going to show you the best moment I have
ever seen during interviews with Trump
supporters in Trump rally attendees.
There is a video of a little kid brought to this
weekend's Trump rally in Selma, North Carolina,
and the reporter asked the kid, What
are you excited for? And the kid goes,
I'm excited to see Joe Biden. Oh, and the mom
goes, Trump, Trump. Now I have a few thoughts
about what might be going on here. Listen
closely to what the mom says. This is the best
clip from a Trump rally I have ever seen.
Speaker 2: I'm excited where you when you
found out there's going to be a rally here.
Speaker 3: I'm just as excited as he is. I
want to tell me about it side. Yeah, yeah.
First rally. Yes, sir. I think they're more
excited than we are. Are you excited? Yes.
Speaker 2: What are you excited for?
I'm the stickers I try.
Speaker 1:
Oh, that is genius. So, OK, so did you guys notice
how the mom kept saying it's the kids who told us
about the rally. It's the kids who are really the
excited ones. It's almost like they're trying to
say, it's like when you go to Disney World and
you're like, They wanted to come. I don't want
to be here, but they wanted to come. But maybe
the kids have no idea what's going on. I mean,
the kid seems to think he's at a Joe Biden rally,
so. This could be one of these things where
they're pushing their desire to be, they're on to
the kids and the kids have no interest in the end,
they're just being dragged in. Whatever it
is, it is one of the most genius clips I have
ever seen from a Trump event. Here's
another one this one seems like a parody.
Two brothers say a lot of really wacky stuff.
Speaker 3: Seems like every meeting I
see is on disgraceful.
Speaker 1: Did you guys
hear that? It's not disgraceful. It's un
disgraceful. Oh wow, that's pretty strong.
Speaker 2: And we ungodly and we support
you guys 100 percent, 100 percent.
Speaker 3: And we just we just want to do it. A
fake news, CNN, MSNBC, all the yo yo or disgrace
to this country. And we're going to come after
Speaker 2: you like your devils. We get saved,
right? Are you guys brother?
Speaker 1: Well, yeah, same. So if I
told you guys, that's a joke, that's the those are
comedians and they troll Trump rallies. That was
satire. Who would say, though, David, that doesn't
make sense. You would say that makes perfect
sense. That makes more sense than that. These guys
really exist as such. Here's another guy at the
Trump rally saying that January 6th was antifa.
Speaker 2: Are we supposed to believe that they
didn't set up the protesters on January six?
Right? That's I mean, that's exactly right.
There's video out there that are trying to
suppress. It's all on people's take toxic
stuff. Yep. Where they had antifa members
inside the White House on that day saying,
We need more people, we need more people.
Speaker 1: Now, why would there be
antifa at the White House when Trump was
president? Does that does that make any sense?
Speaker 2: Petrol in the. Yeah.
Why they were trying to break.
Speaker 1: Oh, OK. So now the
other guy corrects him and goes,
Do you mean the Capitol on the floor?
Speaker 2: And one of the officers, a lady, was in
the window with a megaphone telling people what to
do and where to go? Yeah, yeah, yeah. There's so
many holes in the official narrative about January
Speaker 1: 6th, right? It's just not. None of it
really makes sense. And of course,
like why would Antifa try to?
Keep Trump in office and prevent Biden from
being sworn in. They never have an answer to
that. And lastly, here's a couple of guys who
have spent 30 grand going to Trump rallies.
Speaker 2: Click calls you guys to drive
across the country. I'm just curious,
like how much of your own the
money? You know, obviously your
own money that you've invested to do this.
Speaker 3: So this is my fourth Trump rally.
I probably invested thirty thousand dollars of my
own money coming here, but by the way, invested.
Speaker 1: Not exactly financial literacy,
you know, you're really burning the money,
you're not investing it, I would look at index
funds and maybe a little bit of money in a high
yield savings account. If you're actually looking
for investments, I don't know that going to Trump
rallies really counts as an investment.
Speaker 3: I can tell you in the last year,
it's it's been worse. It's been worse. The
flights are double, the rent cars are double.
Gas is almost $4 a gallon all along the East
Coast. It's getting ridiculous. You know,
I want it back and we want it back to $2 gas.
We want it back to one hundred dollar flights
and we want it back to cheap rental cars.
Speaker 1: Well, I don't know if that's going
to happen because things do get more expensive
over time, but any one of these could be a joke.
Any one of these could be a skit on Saturday
Night Live, without a doubt. And it would be.
It would be more funny if this wasn't a political
movement with teeth that might get people as crazy
as Herschel Walker elected so that we've
now looked at the wacky from the weekend.
But I am going to have to read everybody the Riot
Act, I apologize in the next segment because as
wacky as some of the the supporters are
and as wacky as some of the candidates are,
some of them are leading in polls and it is a
dystopian nightmare that's coming up after the
break. Make sure you're following us on Facebook
at Facebook dot com slash David Pakman show